buenas tardes pues yo creo que es un
poco una mezcla de las dos cosas no por
un lado hay que celebrar porque siempre
estamos dando pasos y avanzando y bueno
pues vamos vamos haciendo piña pero sí
que es cierto que falta mucho por hacer
y qué bueno que siempre hay letra
pequeña no muchas veces parece que se
han dado ciertos pasos pero hay
parte del colectivo que queda fuera y
que a lo mejor no se ha mencionado o
senado por por presas ciertas cosas no
siempre estamos un poco haciendo aguas
pero sí es importante porque
todas las personas que formamos parte
del colectivo lgtb y al final pues por
un lado por el otro siempre estamos
en nuestras propias carnes o en gente
que conocemos de alrededor o con quienes
trabajamos a diario en kit que siempre
hay discriminación de cualquier tipo
verbal física puede haber incluso
psicológica que es incluso peor que la
veces que la física o la verbal
entonces bueno como bien sabéis pues las
personas trans son personas muy
damnificadas las personas y grandes
procesársele gtb y también por todas las
intersecciones ten en cuenta de cada
intersección supone un plano abajo no
para los derechos universales
fundamentales no nos imaginamos una
persona migrante que viene de otro país
que a lo mejor pues tiene alguna alguna
comorbilidad por ejemplo asociada y que
y pues puede ser víctima también de
racismo de xenofobia de xenofobia
transfobia homofobia pues es importante
y luego en las agresiones
que se están dando últimamente se está
se está tomando como mí a la ligera se
estaba normalizando derecho de igual
podemos insultar colectivo les podemos
agredir ha habido casos incluso
el año pasado el caso de samuel ruiz que
fue sorprendido aquí lo mataron de una
paliza en la salida de una discoteca
pues por el hecho de esos presente
género y por el hecho del ahora como
quiere ser no pone ahora realmente sí es
importante porque ahora cómo combatir
esa homofobia la transfobia y la bifobia
cuando siguen promoviendo se leyes como
por ejemplo la que se aprobó
recientemente en florida en estados
unidos que prohíbe enseñar sobre
orientación sexual la identidad de
género
pues me la única manera de combatir todo
esto es visibilizando y dejándonos ver y
saliendo a la calle y haciendo piña y
haciendo fuerza es que no lo que no
podemos hacer es escondernos porque si
no
cuanto más nos escondamos más terreno se
nos va a ganar y aparte creo que en
iquique es que es visibilizar la
naturalidad la normalidad de la
diversidad posible existente en todos
los hacen todos los aspectos entonces
las personas por ejemplo que los
sexuales no se tienen que manifestar
para que no les agregan ni les pregunta
con quién andan o por qué hacen esto
porque 'son ha sido su masa entonces
tenemos que irlo por supuesto el cambio
político es importantísimo si los
partidos que están detrás empiezan a
normalizar en permitir ciertas cosas
incluso a inculcar esas cosas pues luego
a las jóvenes de hoy en día en los goles
de los institutos que estamos viendo
pues lo reproducen y le gritan claro